other common issues I see in my family
law divorce practice
there seems to be a continued belief
that divorce will never happen to
someone I see it all guys will say I
never thought this was going to happen I
thought she was my soulmate
I don't need a prenup
she'll never change and she'll play fair
if we separate or divorce she'll play
fair if we separate uh or divorce I got
a bridge in Brooklyn to sell you if you
think that won't happen I've seen people
at their absolute worst and they just
drag the process out and burn the Earth
just because and the guy didn't do
anything to deserve it he didn't run
away with his secretary or
some Starlet he just could didn't live
up to her disney-esque expectations and
you know no matter even if she hires a
reasonable educated well-educated
attorney experienced attorney they just
go crazy sometimes and you gotta just
deal with it do the best you can and I
just see that like all the time so a
word to the wise think about if marriage
is really necessary if you want to have
children your legacy and I know there
are certain cultures where marriage is
important uh for religious reasons and
cultural reasons but
those reasons when you juxtapose them to
the laws in your jurisdiction
they don't mesh well uh there's never a
good ending so I would ask you to think
about that so so to that point and I
completely agree with everything you've
said tonight you know inclusive of this
but I want to sort of
I want to propose something a little bit
different to you Jonathan because
I get pushback on this you know myself
it's you know it usually comes from the
traditional conservative crowd look I've
got six kids I've got five kids we've
been married forever uh if we got
divorced I would marry her or if I came
back in her life I would marry her again
and I would do it all over again sort of
thing like there's these hardcore guys
that purport publicly they have a great
life their children are amazing their
wife is completely in their frame and
they love them and they would never
leave them or harm them in any way shape
or form
but the problem is is that okay that
that exception to a general rule doesn't
disprove the rule and I'm wondering how
you handle the the traditional
conservative crowd that that basically
just you know distills the town down to
you're not being a man just man up and
get married you know you have a duty
um
like what do you think of those sort of
dialogues and conversations that come up
often like
I don't buy into the mainstream
narrative and I'm telling you this
through the lens of a divorce lawyer
obviously but I'm not jaded at all if
you're hell-bent on following whatever
you know history dictates you should do
or what your culture says what you
should do or your family says good luck
that's why I'm in business and people
like me are in business we end up
untangling the mess uh the odds are
against you uh you can't dispute that
you know the odds are overwhelmingly
against that your marriage will end in
the death of one of you uh so and if
it's a second marriage for either of you
it's overwhelmingly against the odds
that death is going to end the marriage
so
the least you could do is protect
yourself to the greatest extent possible
um but I need you to really think about
is marriage really necessary some of the
best relationships that I'm familiar
with the people are not married and they
don't even live together but they are
really into each other and they see each
other fairly often maybe three four
nights a week and
that's great on a personal note is that
the way that you've structured yours
because that's the way that I've
structured mine non-cohabitating LTR
good that is the way that I have
structured my relationship it's over
three years it's a great relationship uh
we live about 65 miles apart and it's
awesome it's easy to get there she comes
to me wide open uh door either way uh so
and it's great it's just we travel
together and
it's it's a great relationship uh I wish
everybody could experience it uh there
it's it's what I would recommend if it's
something that it's not ideal for
raising children but for guys like us
that are past that point it's right yeah
it's great so now neither of us have to
get on an airplane and see each other
it's not that kind of long distance
relationship she's down at the beach so
uh if I even in the winter I like the
beach so we'll go down there and see her
but and or she'll come to me a lot
closer to the city and uh it just works
out great that way I'm
she does her thing I do my thing and
when we're together it's great so I just
can't see any argument for like living
with a woman or getting married to a
woman
at this stage of life it just it just
doesn't make any sense like I could see
you know the need if you want to raise
kids then you have to go through the
process of vetting her making sure she's
good Mother's stock maybe considering
moving to a state that's friendlier to
Father sort of thing if you live in a
hostile State like there's you know
blanketing it with some kind of
agreement a prenup cohabitation
depending on how you want to structure
it there's there's mechanisms that you
can put in place as you mentioned right
I've had people come to me uh women have
come to me and said look I want to marry
him but he doesn't want to get married
and I'm afraid that if he gets sick and
he can't speak for himself that I'm not
his wife they won't let me into the
hospital like that's a that's an easy
remedy just get a power of attorney a
durable power of attorney you can make
Health Care decisions uh so that's no
reason to get married uh I've heard
other reasons that just really don't
outweigh the potential risks you can
still have great intimacy and phenomenal
relationships without bringing state law
into your life that's how I explain it
so I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the
full-length podcast you can find that
over here that clips from if you're new
to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out